parents visiting their child's school
are frequently greeted with a raft of
impressive sounding but impenetrable
education jargon one result even
informed parents can walk away
frustrated and unsure if their child is
in good hands so here are five questions
to ask before the first day of school
this year they can help cut through the
noise one what's the best thing my child
is going to read this year two what one
or two values are at the heart of our
school's culture and how will they be
applied 3 in the typical month how many
hours will be devoted to tests and test
preparation for what's the one paper or
project that I should expect my child to
come home excited about and five what's
the most important thing you think I can
do to help my child be academically
successful this year these questions are
hard to spend and resistant to jargon
and no matter the answer you'll walk
away with real insight into the year
ahead what do you think makes for a good
classroom let us know in your comments
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI